aquí tenemos una captura de pantalla de
la calculadora gráfica en línea de smos
puedes usarla en de esmas.com y te
invito a que lo hagas después de ver
este vídeo o incluso mientras estoy
haciendo este vídeo pero el objetivo es
pensar en la reflexión de funciones así
que vamos a empezar con algunos ejemplos
digamos que tengo una función f x y es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de x de modo
que eso es lo que parece se ve bastante
razonable
ahora hagamos otra función g de x y voy
a hacer que también sea igual a la raíz
cuadrada de x así que no es de extrañar
que g b x sea graficada justo encima de
fx pero qué pasaría si en lugar de eso
de solo poner la raíz cuadrada de x qué
pasaría si ponemos un signo negativo al
inicio justo allí que crees que va a
pasar cuando haga eso bueno vamos a
probarlo cuando pongo el signo negativo
parece que le dio vuelta al eje x parece
que se reflejó sobre el eje x ahora si
tuviéramos otra función hdx y empezaré
haciéndola idéntica a efe x una vez más
está justo ahí se traza sobre f x en
lugar de poner el signo negativo frente
al signo radical qué pasaría si lo
ponemos dentro del signo radical qué
pasaría si reemplazamos x con menos x
que crees que va a pasar allí bueno
vamos a probarlo si lo reemplazamos eso
lo desplaza sobre el eje y pausa este
vídeo y piensa en cómo te moviste sobre
ambos ejes bueno podríamos hacer otra
estoy quedando sin letras tal vez haré
una cada equis es igual a voy a poner el
signo negativo fuera del signo radical y
luego voy a poner la raíz cuadrada y voy
a poner un signo negativo dentro del
signo radical y fíjate los reflejos
sobre ambos ejes los reflejos sobre el
eje x y el eje y ahora por qué sucede
esto bueno vamos a empezar con gx cuando
pones el signo negativo al frente cuando
llegas todo lo que está en la expresión
que define una función cualquier valor
que hubieras obtenido antes de la
función vas a conseguir lo contrario
entonces cuando x es cero obtenemos 0
cuando x es igual a 1 en lugar de 1
ahora estás tomando el negativo de eso
así que vas a tener menos uno cuando x
es igual a 4 en lugar de obtener 2
positivos ahora vas a tener menos dos
cuando x es igual a 9 en lugar de
obtener 3 positivos ahora obtienes menos
3 entonces espero que tenga sentido
porque poner un signo negativo al inicio
de una expresión entera se va a reflejar
reflejar su gráfica sobre el eje x ahora
qué pasa si reemplazamos x con menos x
bueno una manera de pensarlo es donde
pusiste uno antes eso ahora será menos
uno estás tratando de evaluar la raíz
principal y sabemos que el principio de
la función raíz cuadrada no se define
para menos uno pero cuando x es igual a
menos uno nuestra función original no
estaba definida cuando x es igual a
menos uno pero si tomas el negativo de
eso bueno ahora estás tomando la raíz
principal de uno es por eso que ahora
está definido entonces cualquier valor
que la función hubiera tomado para un
valor dado de x ahora toma ese valor en
el valor opuesto correspondiente de x y
en el valor negativo de esa x y es por
eso que lo gira sobre el eje y esto es
cierto con muchos tipos de funciones no
tenemos que hacer esto solo con una
función con raíz cuadrada probemos otra
función
digamos que intentamos esto para el
elevado a la potencia x ahí la tienes
aquí tenemos una exponencial clásica
ahora digamos que eje x es igual a menos
elevada a la potencia x y si sucede lo
que esperamos que suceda esto la
reflejará sobre el eje x entonces menos
elevado a la potencia x y de hecho eso
es lo que pasa y luego como reflejamos
la gráfica sobre el eje y bueno hagamos
una hd x eso va a ser igual a el elevado
a en lugar de poner una equis pondremos
menos x menos equis y ahí lo tienes
fíjense se reflejó sobre el eje y ahora
los ejemplos que acabo de hacer son
expresiones muy simples imaginemos algo
que sea un poco más complejo
digamos que fx vamos a poner un buen
polinomio de grado superior así que
digamos que es x a la tercera potencia
menos 2 x al cuadrado eso se ve bien y
en realidad vamos a añadir otro término
aquí más 2x y quiero que sea menos 2x
quiero ver que se acentúen algunas de
esas curvas está bien es un gráfico
bastante interesante
ahora como lo reflejaría sobre el eje x
bueno la forma en que lo haría es que
podría definir una función g x podría
hacerlo de dos maneras podría decir que
eje x es igual a menos f x y conseguimos
eso de modo que esencialmente tome toda
esta expresión y la multiplique por
menos 1 y fíjense que se está reflejando
sobre el eje x otra forma en que
podríamos haberlo hecho es poner un
signo negativo por equis a la tercera
potencia menos 2 x al cuadrado menos 2x
y luego cerramos esos paréntesis y
obtenemos el mismo efecto ahora qué
pasaría si quisiéramos reflejar la sobre
el eje y pues bien en lugar de poner un
signo negativo en toda la expresión lo
que queremos hacer es reemplazar
nuestras x con una x negativa así que
podrías hacerlo así podrías decir que va
a ser
efe de menos x y eso tiene el efecto en
todos los lugares en los que viste una x
antes de reemplazarla con una x negativa
y fíjense que hizo exactamente lo que
esperamos la reflejo sobre el eje y
ahora otra manera en que podríamos
haberlo hecho solo para que quede claro
eso es lo mismo que menos x a la tercera
potencia menos 2 por menos x al cuadrado
menos 2 por menos equis y por supuesto
podríamos simplificar esa expresión pero
fíjense que es exactamente la misma idea
y si quisiéramos reflejar la tanto en el
eje x como en el eje y bueno ya le hemos
reflejado sobre el eje y para reflejarla
sobre el eje x ubs se acabo de borrarlo
para darle la vuelta para girar lo
también sobre el eje x sólo pondría un
signo negativo al inicio así que pongo
un signo negativo al inicio y ahí lo
tienes esto se reflejó tanto en el eje x
como en el eje y puedes hacerlo en
cualquier orden y llegarás a esta curva
verde ahora una forma más fácil de
escribir eso hubiera sido solo en
negativo df - equis y habría llegado a
ese mismo lugar así que vea de smos
pruébalo es muy bueno que desarrolles
esta intuición y en ti
lo que realmente está sucediendo